partiamo con una domanda il libro avrà
un futuro e in particolare il libro dei
libri la bibbia avrà un futuro
questa domanda si pone in questo inizio
del xxi secolo caratterizzato da una
drammatica guerra dei media abbiamo uno
scontro in atto tra la stampa ei media
digitali
gli ebook e tablet contro i libri linci
clop edile diderot surclassata dal suo
alias digitale partecipativo wikipedia
giornali magazine aggrediti e minacciati
dai motori di ricerca è sotto gli occhi
di tutti questo conflitto e può portare
a una vera e propria apocalisse del
libro
ma tornando alla domanda questo pò
calissi potrà portare con sé anche il
più importante libro la bibbia oppure no
per dare una risposta
torniamo indietro nella storia e
dell'apocalisse del libro passiamo alla
genesi l'origine della bibbia siamo sul
sinai nel secondo millennio avanti
cristo dove si combatte la prima grande
guerra dei media che vede contrapporsi
l'alfabeto al geroglifico in questa
guerra che vediamo rappresentata con
mosè che alza le tavole si colloca anche
l'origine della bibbia che vedremo
coincide con l'invenzione dell'alfabeto
dice il libro dell'esodo le tavole erano
opera di dio
la scrittura e la scrittura di dio
scolpita sulle tavole è la prima volta
che nella bibbia si parla di scrittura i
patriarchi precedenti si esprimevano
diciamo in forma orale
qui invece ecco che compare sulle tavole
la scrittura
cosa ci dice l'archeologia l'archeologia
dice
che in effetti l'alfabeto nasce sul
sinai e qui noi dobbiamo confutare
quello che normalmente scritto sui libri
di testo cioè che i fenici hanno
inventato un alfabeto non è vero
l'alfabeto è stato introdotto sul sinai
guardate questi segni a sinistra c'è
proprio il nome di dio el scritto in
alfabeto proto sinaitico e la cosa
singolare che le lettere sono dei segni
visivi un toro in particolare qui sulla
destra vediamo l'evoluzione della
tecnica alfabetica dal segno della
visibile di un ideogramma il segno del
toro si arriva attraverso una serie di
deformazioni a una lettera alla nostra
lettera a
in realtà la cosa interessante qui c'è
un'indagine anche un po simbolica la
prima lettera significa toro bue e in
effetti è l'immagine di un bue ma la
testimonianza drammatica del conflitto
sta proprio nella prima dichiarazione
che la scrittura di dio fa non ti farai
idolo né immagine alcuna
ed è proprio il primo comandamento che
proibisce le immagini siamo nel contesto
di una drammatica contesa tra la la
cultura visiva e la cultura fonetica
questa questo diciamo scena si compie
con l'atto finale
l'uccisione del vitello alla distruzione
del segno visivo perché la lettera nasca
deve morire
l'immagine e vediamo in questa in questo
filmato come ciò accade proprio con la
distruzione dell'idolo il vitello d'oro
da parte di mosè
la distruzione fisica dell'idolo
coincide nella nostra psiche alla
eliminazione della cultura visiva che ha
accompagnato l'uomo per decine di
migliaia di anni da quel momento nasce
l'occidente
nasce in un certo senso la coscienza
rispetto all'inconscio nasce la razione
alta rispetto al mito questa storia si
può esprimere anche in altre forme
vediamo un altro modalità si passa dall
egitto al sinai poi tre sola finisca
grecia roma aleph diventa alfa lettera
greca poi diventa qui si destina
l'occidente in sostanza l'alfabeto e la
base il codice che struttura la cultura
ebraica anche islamica in realtà la
filosofia greca e quindi tutta la nostra
civiltà che ancora oggi studia
alfabeticamente la nostra esperienza
cognitiva è sostanzialmente alfabetica
da circa tremila anni vediamo da un
punto di vista geografico come avvenuto
a questo passaggio
geroglifico alla lettera alfabetica in
grecia
questo tipo di passaggio in realtà
appunto si basa sulla riepilogo
fondamentale di una guerra che c'è stata
ma non è l'unica che la bibbia
affrontato in questo caso avete visto la
bibbia vinto cioè la nuova scrittura si
è imposta sulla civiltà precedente
l'ideogramma il geroglifico in realtà
dopo questa guerra e ce ne sono state
altre in particolare l'era cristiana
vede un capovolgimento di fronte perché
dio incarnato e visibile diventa anche
rappresentabile quindi dopo un conflitto
nell'ottavo secolo dell'iconoclastia in
cui ci fu una disputa si può usare le
immagini per la conoscenza sacra la
risposta fu sì nacque una stagione
incredibile che l'italia ha conosciuto
in modo straordinario la stagione della
bibbia per immagini quindi le cattedrali
in arte sacra la miniatura
ecco lutero un altro capovolgimento e
quindi con la stampa ce l'avevi incidere
alfabeto siamo di fronte all'era
digitale
cosa succederà rivediamo questo
rapidamente in un'altra forma questa la
rappresentazione originale da cultura
umana attraverso due diciamo fasce
fondamentali il codice iconico il codice
alfabetico 50.000 avanti cristo
gli idoli le scritture rupestri ma ecco
che arriva a mosè l'alfabeto i codici e
destinano poi la bibbia ebraica
cristiana successivamente di nuovo c'è
un conflitto stavolta contro il mito in
grecia da cui nasce la filosofia
occidentale
siamo vedete della cultura dal contesto
iconico passa al contesto alfabetico il
corano resta pienamente in contesto
alfabetico pensate alla proibizione
delle immagini che ancora oggi
oggetto di dispute le vignette no sono
una profanazione del primo comandamento
anche per gli islamici avviene nel viii
secolo 1 il conflitto di nuovo che
riporta invece i codici nel contesto
visivo miniature arte sacca cattedrali
di nuovo un conflitto la stampa ci sia
un e scisma d'occidente lutero gutenberg
la stampa oggi dove siamo
e qui entriamo nella pars con storia
dell'intervento cioè come può essere
immaginato il prossimo libro e la
prossima bibbia quindi abbiamo visto che
analizzando la storia della bibbia non è
solo un libro la libia precede il libro
e era stata rappresentata e letta anche
come arte sacra miniatura gregoriano
forme liturgiche cattedrali quindi e qui
c'è un altro guru del nostro tempo come
dice steve jobs ipad is a iconic cioè
questi strumenti sono iconici l'immagine
torna essere prevalente centrale quindi
perché non riscoprire una tradizione
fondamentale medievale che è la bibbia
può però nell'epoca in cui l'alfabeto
era passato in secondo piano nelle
nostre cattedrali si leggeva la bibbia
per immagini la bibbia dei poveri era
una tradizione molto consolidata di
alfabetizzazione cognitiva della bibbia
attraverso le immagini
ma un altro concetto importante che
deriva dalla diciamo evoluzione del
libro elettronico è il libro aumentato
da questo punto di vista possiamo
riferirci a un altro referente cioè le
le miniature cos'era la miniatura in un
contesto in cui non esisteva la stampa
il libro era molto prezioso avveniva una
forte arricchimento aumento del libro
attraverso immagini simboli decorazioni
che trasformavano questo oggetto in
qualcosa di completamente diverso
rispetto a quello che oggi è un libro
stampato e perché non pensare una
miniatura digitale quindi alla
possibilità che dopo l'epoca della
stampa
si ritorni a un libro aumentato con una
miniatura digitale che possa arricchire
la lettura con altri contesti e diciamo
media
un altro aspetto oggi qual è la sua beta
universale non quello latino non quello
cirillico ma è l'icona da quando nei
computer è stata introdotta
l'interfaccia uomo macchina della
cosiddetta scrivania le icone sono
diventate l'unico vero alfabeto
universale condiviso da arabi cinesi
occidentali ma anche qui c'è una
risposta
esiste un codice simbolico nella bibbia
e quindi il simbolo può tornare a
diventare una interfaccia grafica del
testo quindi indici simbolici ad esempio
non alfabetici la scrittura cinese
simbolico del più rispetto alla nostra
che ha un ordine alfabetico
un altro aspetto fondamentale qual è il
media più ricco
oggi nel settore digitale sono i giochi
i videogiochi hanno superato il cinema e
per fatturato sono pervasivi ne vedete
presso soprattutto le nuove generazioni
ma è pensabile una gamification della
bibbia
intanto che implicazioni ci sono come
diceva cicerone la memoria può essere
aiutata attraverso la simulazione
virtuale diceva cicerone la memoria
artificiale è costituito da luoghi
immagine come i videogiochi luoghi e
immagini il tutto vivibile in modo
attivo ma in fondo anche la bibbia nel
medioevo con i gargoyle con le dispute
filosofiche con tutta una serie di
esperienze avevano componenti di
ludicità e quindi perché non può essere
vero come diceva in talk jazz shell che
i giochi diventano medium per la vita di
ogni giorno e quindi verificare anche il
libro sicuramente sarà una strada che
andrà percorsa
il libro non è più bidimensionale
diventa tridimensionale o immersivo
quindi è possibile che il libro stand
libro sia intorno a noi come una sfera
che ci circonda
applicato al terreno storico della
bibbia in particolare questo diventa uno
stargate una sorta di macchina del tempo
che ci può portare al tempo di abramo
mosè e cristo e quindi un altro modo
ulteriore di pensare un futuro della
bibbia
oppure in modo ancora diverso
il libro come guida sul luogo pensate
una visita dei luoghi della bibbia
attraverso una guida che ci consente di
immergersi in quello che era incontrare
la bibbia nei luoghi della bibbia questo
ad esempio è molto plausibile
realizzarla con le tecnologia della
realtà aumentata
abbiamo fatto un percorso questo
percorso ci ha portato a esplorare cos'è
un libro elettronico in che modo può
evolvere e in che modo può essere
applicato a un contesto specifico come
quello della bibbia l'ultimo aspetto
rilevante riguarda la componente sociale
social reading è un'espressione che
soprattutto nel contesto amazon ma in
altri contesti indica il fatto che oggi
la lettura e condivisa cioè noi possiamo
condividere con altre persone quello che
leggiamo lo possiamo commentare lo
possiamo inviare e questo è un aspetto
distintivo del libro elettronico e della
pagina elettronica ma se noi guardiamo
la parola chiesa vuol dire community
quindi la condivisione attorno al testo
è sempre stato un fenomeno fondamentale
e allora ecco che la bibbia stessa il
libro può tornare a essere un social
media e qui concludo sostanzialmente
direi di sì questo percorso ci porta a
pensare che la bibbia è il libro avranno
un futuro questo futuro sarà digitali
grazie